_ This is super exciting
because it's not the academic
problem of NLP,
of Natural Language Processing,
understanding dialogue.
This is like the real world.
- [Guest] This is real world.
- The stakes are high in
the sense that customers
get frustrated quickly,
people get frustrated quickly.
So you have to get it right.
You have to get that interaction right.
So it's, I love it.
So from that perspective,
what are the challenges today?
What are the problems that
really need to be solved
in the next few years.
- I think first and foremost,
as I mentioned that
to get the basics right are still true.
Basically, even the one shot request,
which we think of as transaction request
needs to work magically,
no question about that.
If it doesn't turn your light on and off,
you'll be super frustrated.
Even if I can complete
the night out for you and
not do that, that is unacceptable
as a customer, right?
So that, you have to get the
foundational understanding
going where you will.
The second aspect when I
said more conversational,
is as you imagine, is
more about reasoning.
It is really about figuring
out what the latent goal is
of the customer, based on what
I have the information now,
and the history.
What's the next best thing to do?
So that's a complete
reasoning and decision making
problem just like your self-driving car,
but the goal is still more finite.
Here, it evolves.
Environment is super hard in self-driving.
And the cost of a mistake is huge.
Here, but there are
certain similarities but,
if you think about how many
decisions Alexa is making
or evaluating at any given time,
it's a huge hypothesis space.
We're only talked about so far,
about what I think of
reactive decision in terms of
you ask for something and
Alexa is reacting to it.
If you bring the proactive part,
which is Alexa having hunches,
say any given instance,
Danny, it's really a decision
at any given point based
on the information.
Alexa has to determine what's
the best thing it needs to do.
So these are the ultimate
A.I. problem with decisions
based on the information you have.